[Music]  it's cold  Jessie's too used to the beach hey  Islander what can I say  look even the seas turning to ice  Wow  [Music]  a walking talking snowman you really are  alive  hello Olaf are these our friends hmm  nope  never met him don't know anyone blue  green or wasabi spikes  [Applause]  yeah give me strength  [Music]  whoa  [Music]  take this  [Music]  Oh  [Music]  that's amazing you can control ice  control it no all I ever do is hurt  people this is my home now I can't go  back I don't want to hurt anyone Roxas  does exist his hearts inside my heart  the other Twilight town is just data so  what will Elsa except light or darkness  I know I want to know well good for you  but guess what I won't let her fall to  darkness  [Music]  this key plate is that Mickey you're too  late  [Music]  you